uh
so
the title is uh rather long it's about
the complexity of fixed point
computation problems defined by algebra
for algebraically defined functions
but i was
quite influenced by frank's email who uh
when he pointed out to us that you know
we we need to be careful about how many
slides we're trying to go through and i
realized that
it's much more sensible if i try to
focus on a particular sub-topic
and this is what i will try to do
fairly shortly after the start of the
talk is to focus on algorithms for
branching markov decision processes and
probabilistic min max polynomial bellman
equations for them and the some of the
key things that i would like to be able
to get to uh which i think would be of
interest to some of the people in this
audience is a generalization of newton's
method that works uh
on these on the piecewise differentiable
functions defined by these bellman
equations and not only works but allows
us to obtain a polynomial time algorithm
for approximating the value of these
branching mdps
and i'd also like to get to some
some
nice open problems at the end that i'd
like to tell you about but i i do want
to spend a little bit of time at the
beginning
giving you the complex complexity
landscape of
what where these problems sit in
in my world view of the complexity okay
so six point computation problems
everybody knows brower's fixed point
theorem every continuous function from a
compact convex subset of euclidean space
to itself has a fixed point
and
computationally we're
assuming somehow
many many computational problems boil
down to
we're given
a function somehow
a brower function of this kind and we're
asked to compute or approximate a fixed
point so of course in general all of the
fixed points may be irrational valued so
when we say compute we don't necessarily
mean exactly we're often happy with
approximation
but what do we mean by approximation and
there are two sort of different standard
notions of what one might mean by
approximating a fixed point
and the two different notions have
rather different complexity implications
so in in different contexts so what one
notion would be
that we're given this function and what
we want to compute is
a point a rational vector that is almost
fixed
by the function so
we you know the the point is not moved
by more than epsilon and for
concreteness i'm fixing the l infinity
norm but in general one could imagine
other
norms so it doesn't matter so
a different notion is
near approximation of a fixed point and
here what we want is we want to compute
a rational vector in the domain
which is near an actual fixed point
almost
are almost points near and your point or
can they no so in general and so of
course in the limit yes in the limit
it's true but it turns out that it's not
the case you can have
in fact
for for example the
let's say nash's functions for uh
you know nash equilibrium which are
brower functions it turns out that you
could be
excruciatingly close almost fixed point
right but be nowhere near the unique
nash equilibrium of the game that you're
studying okay so and so these things may
make a difference in general so near in
general tends to be a stronger notion
and in fact formally
you can show for so-called polynomially
continuous functions meaning once you've
got
a reasonable bound on the modulus of
continuity of the function then if you
get near approximation you've got almost
approximation but not the other way
around okay
so in this talk i'm interested in near
approximation
you need to know the existence of a
fixed point yes brower's fixed point
theorem tells you the existence okay
okay thanks so uh it guarantees it for
you okay so now we're so we're
interested in near approximation and not
only that i'm interested in worst case
complexity and i'm interested in worst
case complexity in the touring model of
computation
okay
so okay
so we can define
complexity classes that essentially
capture a whole
plethora of such fixed point problems
and here's uh a complexity class well
i'll give you two versions of it one is
a real valued version so this is not
really you you can't make sense of it in
the touring model the other is an
approximation version fixed p sub a is
the approximate version of it and that's
the one that
we should focus on in some sense but so
these are classes of total search
problems
and what are they so the input is given
to us
by an algebraic circuit or straight line
program
using gates plus times and max and
rational constants positive or negative
rational constants
having n input variables x1 through xn
and n output gates
such that the circuit represents in the
obvious way a continuous function
from the unit n cube to itself now
and you might say well how do you know
it
maps the unit and cubed it to itself
either you can just be told that or you
can actually syntactically constrain it
using max and min so that it it does do
so okay
uh so in the case of the approximate
version we're also given an error
parameter epsilon as input okay
now what do we want we want to compute
a
fixed point of f or in the approximate
version we want to compute an epsilon
near approximate fixed point okay so
everybody with me right
now we close these search problems under
suitable reductions in the case of the
real valued one we have to be careful
what notion of reduction we mean and
there we just mean that
you transform the problem into a fixed
point problem and then any fixed point
that's given back to you through a
separable linear transformation you can
get back the answer to your problem and
in the case of in the case of the
approximate version it's just the
standard polynomial time search problem
reductions okay
the resulting complex
class we call fixed p and respectively
fixed pa and it may not seem like a
particularly robust class but trust me
it is it's very robust you can add all
kinds of other operators to this class
and it will not uh
enhance its power you can change the
domain to any convex
polytope domain you can even have
ellipsoid domains it doesn't change the
power of this class
repeat those definitions
which part of it
so so this is the definition of the
class any problem that is reducible to
computation of a fixed point of an
of a function given to you by an
algebraic circuit using gates plus times
in max
that's it right
and if the function maps the unit n cube
to itself
any
function that is any problem that is
reducible to that think of it as just
polynomial time reducibility
the reason why i had to be a little bit
careful is because in the real value
case i have to tell you well what do you
mean by polynomial time reducibility if
i give you a real value vector
how are you going to look at it and i'm
saying all the only way i'm going to
look at it that way is just a separable
linear
elements of this transformation are
functions sequences
the elements of these this this is a
search problem class so
the basically i give you such a function
i i i give you
such a function
specified by a circuit and i ask you
give me any fixed point for it or give
me any approximate fixed point for it
i'm just trying to understand what is
fixed
it's a total search problem class search
problem classes are
class class of problems where the input
is a string
okay
and the output can be any one of
the solutions to that problem right now
for example in discrete search problems
like for example i don't know
take the problem of
finding a
hamiltonian cycle in a graph
phrased as a search problem is give me a
hamiltonian cycle
right there are maybe more than one of
the hamiltonian cycle any one of them
will do okay
here this is a search problem where i
say any one of them will do okay anyone
me this
sub a fixed sub a what is the exact
meaning of that clause that it's
specified right here
it says
i also give you an epsilon and i give
you the so i'm kind of conflating two
definitions together the the sub a one
is the approximate one the other one is
this uh you know it's living in a
in a model of computation that we don't
know how to deal with namely a real
valued computation but nevertheless
these both have
you know these are very robust classes
and they have a complete problem in both
cases
computing a nash equilibrium or epsilon
approximating a nash equilibrium in the
case of fixed pa for a game with three
or more players
given the game and given epsilon is
respectively fixed speed complete and
fixed pa complete and this is not the
only complete problem computing market
market equilibria for various kinds of
markets and so forth there's a lot of
complete problems for this class
um
okay
now you might have heard of a complexity
class called p-pad
defined by papu mitchu in the early 90s
i don't want to dwell on this side as i
mentioned
i i really want to get to the latter
part the only thing i want to mention is
that if you've heard of p-pad before
p-pad corresponds precisely to the
piecewise linear fragment of fixed p
namely restrict yourself to just the
gates plus and max and multiplication by
rational constant and take the same
definition and that's p-pad
okay
um
and scarf's algorithm also tells you
that
almost fixed point computation for
polynomially computable polynomially
continuous brower functions
are
is a problem that's in p-pad okay so in
other words uh
you can extract from scarf's algorithm
the fact that
computing an almost fixed point for
well-behaved functions is a problem that
you can basically boil down to the
piecewise linear fragment of fixed p
okay
okay
so the and there's these well-known
results but
going back to 2006 by dasgalakis
and uh chan dang that say computing a
so-called epsilon nash equilibrium which
is something that is a almost nash
equilibrium for a three-player game is
p-pad complete and computing an exact
rational nash equilibrium for two-player
games is p-pad complete for two-player
games the underlying functions are
piecewise linear
and scarce algorithm however does not in
general
give us a way to compute a point that is
near an actual fixed point okay and that
so computing something that's near an
actual fixed point is not
uh reducible to kind of a piecewise
linear
fixed point computation problems for
you know in other words there's a
distinct difference for these more
for this more enriched uh complexity
class fixed p which includes
multiplication
than for the piecewise linear fragment
okay
and in fact we can
pinpoint precisely the extra hardness
that you get
for approximation problems uh for this
complexity class
fixed p
and for many problems in it
by
discussing a very basic what seems like
a ridiculously simple
decision problem which is
you're given as input an arithmetic
circuit or straight line program that
just has input one and plus times and
minus gates
right
and you're just trying to decide whether
the output value of this circuit so and
so there's some designated output gate
and you're trying to decide is the
output value
positive
okay so you know you might say to
yourself what the heck why don't i just
evaluate the circuit so what's wrong
with that
why can't we just evaluate the circuit
because of repeated squaring the numbers
could get astronomically big even with a
circuit of size
n
you could build up numbers that are of
the form two to the two to the n so you
couldn't write down those numbers in
binary representation in a succinct way
necessarily
so and this posits lp actually captures
essentially
the the power of polynomial time in the
unit cost arithmetic ram model of
computation in the sense that it's
actually
complete under turing reductions for if
you like
for this class okay
so
so in this really lovely paper by uh
some some of the people in the audience
they showed that pauses lp is decidable
in the counting hierarchy so if you
don't know this class the never mind but
it's somewhere just below polynomial
space
and nothing better is known so we don't
know that for example this is in np or
in the polynomial time hierarchy and so
forth okay
okay
so
so now let me relate this positive lp
problem to even getting any non-trivial
approximation
of for example
a nash equilibrium
so any non-trivial approximation of a
nash equilibrium is positive hard in
what sense so for every
epsilon greater than zero you can reduce
positive cell p to the following problem
you're given a three-player game with
the promise that it has a unique nash
equilibrium which is fully mixed
and
the probability with which player one
plays its first pure strategy let's say
it's some some specific pure strategy is
either less than epsilon or greater than
one minus epsilon
and you can't tell which of the two is
the case without solving positive lp
okay so
in other words any non-trivial
approximation of nash equilibria which
happened to be the fixed points of the
kinds of functions that i was
describing to you before
is
going to be at least as hard as this
problem which really is a linchpin
problem for
uh
understanding the difference between the
complex complexity
uh
understanding the difference between
polynomial time and the turing model
versus the arithmetic unit cost arithmet
arithmetic model okay
okay
so what makes these fixed point problems
hard or easy so all of these problems
are in general not np hard because
existence of a solution is
guaranteed p-pad hardness
sort of papillary misuse notion of p-pad
p-pad hardness captures a combinatorial
difficulty of computing or even almost
approximating a fixed point
but it does not but but there can also
be an additional numerical difficulty
for near approximating a fixed point
which is not captured by p-pad hardness
namely it is captured by this positive
lp hardness and the interesting thing is
that these two difficulties are really
orthogonal in the sense that you
encounter
fixed point problems that have only one
of these difficulties but not the other
and and the other way around and there's
also a bunch of problems that have some
kind of intermediate status in terms of
their difficulty
and so 6p complete problem 6pa complete
problems have both of these difficulties
so and this is
there's no way on earth that i can do
justice to this picture what i'm trying
to depict here is that there's two
different axes combinatorial difficulty
and numerical difficulty
and there are you know sort of problems
that are combinatorially rather hard
fixed point problems that are
combinatory rather hard but there are
also some intermediate combinatorial
difficulties that you encounter so pg
hearts stands for parody game hard and
if you don't know what that means ignore
it
but on the other axis the surpasses lp
hardness stands for
numerical difficulty and there are also
some intermediate uh difficulty problems
like square root some hardness and so
forth so these are problems that we we
don't have a good handle on but and
they're they seem more tractable
potentially than positive lp hardness
but nobody has any
uh
answer for it so okay i've laid out the
landscape and now you can just forget
about what i said what i wanted to do is
say
lay out the complexity landscape within
which i want
the world view to be set for the rest of
what i'm going to talk about now i'm
going to talk about much more tame
uh
fixed point problems namely we're going
to restrict ourselves to monotone
algebraically defined functions so in a
sense a monotone fragment of what i was
talking about before
and as we'll see these have many
applications okay
so let's
talk about a classic stochastic process
multi-type branching processes
so um
uh so these go back to komogorov and
even before that in the one type case
they go back to galton and watson in the
19th century and so forth so the very
very rich history and probability okay
so what is this process
um
you
you have a bunch of different types in
the population you can imagine
a pop a population of different cell
types
there are red cells blue cells and green
cells okay
in each generation
an object of let's say of the red type
will in the next generation give rise as
offspring
potentially it will give rise to two
blue ones a green one and a red one with
probability one third
or it will give rise to a blue one and a
red one with probability one half or it
will give rise
to nothing meaning it will die with
probability 1 6.
okay
likewise for a blue type
with probability one fourth it'll give
rise to two blue two red ones and with
three fourths it'll die okay
and a green one with probability one
it'll give rise to that right so for
example if we start with one red object
then in the next generation we might
have used that rule
and generated that right so with one
third probability this might have
happened
and then in the next generation the blue
ones might have died
and the red one might have also died but
the green one without choice had to give
rise to that
and
we keep going so this gives essentially
this is a stochastic process generating
a random labeled tree starting from one
object right
and but in some cases we may end up
becoming extinct the entire tree
is finite okay but it need not be finite
okay
so here's a question what is the
probability of eventual extinction
starting with one red object
so let's write down some polynomial
equations for this
so let's associate a variable x sub red
to this
to the probability of eventually going
extinct starting with one red object
okay
so what should this probability be well
it's not too difficult to see that well
with one sixth probability we're
immediately going to go extinct
and then with one third probability what
we have to do is
independently we have to go extinct from
one from two blue ones a green one and a
red one so essentially what we're doing
is if we associate similar random
similar variables with the probability
of going extinct from one blue type then
essentially we have this monomial
representing the probability of going
extinct if we chose that and we have
that monomial for that
and so forth right and we can likewise
write down equations for the other types
right
so we get non-linear fixed point
equations and equations in n unknowns
the fact is that the extinction
probabilities are the least fixed point
in the unit n cube in the unit 3 cube in
this case
of these equations
least fixed point means it's a good
question these happen to be and i'll
i'll discuss that i'll describe that in
in a minute
so
these happen to be monotone functions
the right hand sides here are monotone
and the the mapping so maybe
let me do it like this
so i'll explain at least in two seconds
okay so look at the polynomials on the
right-hand sides here they're very
special
they're what they're what i'll call a
probabilistic polynomial each of them is
a probabilistic polynomial basically the
coefficients are non-negative and they
sum to one
okay
a probabilistic polynomial system of
equations is n equations and n unknowns
where all the right hand sides are
probabilistic polynomials right you're
with me okay
so every multi-type branching process
with n-types corresponds to one of these
and vice versa
and what i'll call a monotone polynomial
is a polynomial where the coefficients
are non-negative but do not necessarily
sum to one
okay
monotone polynomial systems are defined
similarly okay
well sorry this should be monotone right
so monotone polynomials are defined
similarly
so
here are some basic facts
so a probabilistic polynomial system
not only is it a brower function not
only does it map the unit end cube to
itself but it's also a monotone map
so by monitoring does everybody here
know what a monotone map is oh no okay
so i'll have to write that down
f
from domain to domain d where let's say
this domain is any uh lattice but it can
let's just pick so a function from the
unit n cube
to itself
is monotone
if
for all x
y
in
if
x less than or equal to y coordinate
wise
then
f of x is less than or equal to f of y
coordinate wise
okay so that's what it means to be
monotone okay
is that clear yeah okay so these this is
a these are this defines a monotone map
from the unit n cube to itself and
monotone polynomial systems if you
basically extend the non-negative orth
end with infinity
they define a monotone map from
uh
basically the non-negative ortho
with infinity attached to itself okay
and
and you might ask wait a second what's
the arithmetic it's just the standard
semi-ring when you attach the positive
infinity to that
now a probabilistic polynomial system
has at least fixed point in the unit n
cube and this follows directly from
tarsky's fixed point theorem tarsky's
fixed point theorem tells you any
monotone map from a lattice to itself
not only has the least fixed point but
it has a lattice of fixed points and
so there's also greatest fixed points
and so forth but i don't want to
dwell on it but the so
this is a freebie a fixed point theorem
gives you that and likewise tarsky's
fixed point theorem tells you that any
monotone polynomial system has a least
fixed point in including possibly some
coordinates or maybe all coordinates
that are infinity
but
we'll call it monotone polynomial system
feasible if it so happens to have a
non-negative real least fixed point
okay so what does it mean to be a least
fixed point it means that you are a
fixed point and you are coordinate wise
less than or equal to any other fixed
point in the non-negative orthogon okay
okay good
furthermore
uh
the least fixed point you can obtain
as the simply the limit of iterating the
polynomial system or whatever it is that
you have iterating it starting from the
zero vector so you're doing what you
like value iteration or others call it
piezo iteration i mean there's a hundred
names for
this okay
uh
but now
and again the least fixed point
corresponds to the vector of extinction
probabilities that we want to compute
for branching processes and for more
general monotone polynomial systems it
actually defines something called the
partition function for the corresponding
weighted context-free grammar but i'm
not going to
dwell on that okay
so the question is can we compute these
guys efficiently can we compute them in
polynomial time
so
let's use a standard workhorse of
numerical methods newton's method um so
newton's method we i mean i don't need
to tell people here what newton's method
is but
restricted to the polynomial systems
that we're trying to solve the
expression for newton's method looks
like that in other words we're looking
at the jacobian mate so this p
p prime is the jacobian matrix of the
polynomials on the right hand side of
these equations and this is what
it looks like okay
so everybody with me
okay
so
so we can decompose a system of such
equations
into its strongly connected components
so so yesterday pablo perlo was giving a
talk about sort of chordal
decompositions here i'm talking about a
much more basic kind of decomposition
this is just you you look at
the variable dependency graph where
suppose you have an equation x i is
equal to p i x right and suppose some
variable x j occurs with a non-negative
with a positive coefficient on the right
hand side then you have a in your
variable dependency graph you have an
edge from x i to x j
and it's if you think about it it's sort
of
brain that obvious that you what you
want to do is decompose such systems of
equations into strongly connected
components and solve them bottom up
because there are parts of your system
that don't even depend on other parts of
your system okay
now if you do such a decomposition and
importantly if you eliminate the zero
variables
in your system of equations by by zero
variables i mean those variables that
will evaluate to zero in the least fixed
point
they can actually be detected
very easily by by doing just an and or
graph analysis it doesn't you don't even
have to look at the numbers in in the
polynomials
uh you so once you eliminate those if
you start from the zero vector both for
pps's and more generally for all
feasible monotone polynomial systems
newton's method converges monotonically
to the least fixed point solution okay
in our original papers on this stuff we
gave no upper bounds at all for the
number of iterations uh that might be
required we actually proved pos slp
hardness
for any non-trivial approximation of the
least fixed point for monotone
polynomial systems associated with a
model that's a bit more general in fact
uh quite more general than the
these multi-type branching processes
that i described to you called recursive
markov chains so i want to just describe
that to you
in in a second so so this is an example
of a recursive markov chain so
think of this as a finite state markov
chain except it can call itself
recursively these are actually used as
uh
sort of
basic models of probabilistic procedural
programs so imagine you've got a
procedure a
that with three-fourths probability
recursively calls itself
and regardless of what value is returned
whether value one is returned or value
two is returned it recursively calls
itself again
okay and then with these probabilities
it ends up going to the the you know to
the two different exits which you can
think of as the two different possible
values that it could return okay
so the question is what is the
probability of terminating at exit two
starting from the entry
and again in a very simple way we can
write down equations for this in the
same way that we did before
so
let's write down equations corresponding
to the probability of terminating at
exit 1 and terminating at exit 2.
terminating at exit 2 well with
one-fourth probability i do it directly
but with one-half probability if you if
you calculate it you'll see that the
probability that i will terminate at
exit 2
i might have to do it recursively either
by going through here and then going
through there or by going through there
and then going through there right and
if you just write it down you get these
polynomials
the coefficients no longer sum to
less than or equal to one
these polynomials nevertheless have at
least fixed point in the unit n cube
which gives the termination
probabilities that we're interested in
okay
and unfortunately any non-trivial
approximation of these termination
probabilities is positive hard for these
more general recursive markov chains
even though
newton's method monotonically converges
from zero
to this these values
so
uh and and i i and i
don't i i don't have time to explain it
but in fact the approximation of this
least fixed point can be put in this
earlier complexity class that i had
defined fixed p
okay
fix pa okay so in other words we can
boil it down to a unique in fact power
fixed point computation problem for
algebraically defined functions
okay
now what is newton's worst case behavior
for these kinds of systems so this was
studied by
uh esparza kiefer and lutenberger
after after our initial work where we
showed
newton's monotonically always converges
to the least fixed point what these guys
looked at they looked at it
in more detail and firstly they gave
some bad examples very in fact rather
simple bad examples
that show that even for
probabilistic polynomial systems where
the
least fixed point solution is the all
one vector
newton's method requires exponentially
many iterations as a function of the
encoding size of the system of equations
even to converge to within one bit of
precision in other words to give you
additive errors strictly less than one
half
it requires exponentially many
iterations as a function of the encoding
size of the system of equations okay
and for strongly uh connected equation
systems they also gave an exponential
upper bound but they they didn't give an
upper bound
when the system of equations is not
strongly connected but more recently we
gave a matching exponential upper bound
for all of the these mon basically any
feasible monotone polynomial system
there's an exponential upper bound on
how long it will take for newton to
converge within desired precision
but okay that's not what i'm interested
in i i want to tell you about this which
is that for these probabilistic
polynomial systems we can actually get a
polynomial time algorithm using newton's
method
and so in other words
given a probabilistic polynomial system
we can compute a rational vector within
j bits of precision
in time polynomial both in the encoding
size of the system and in j and this is
just in the standard turing model of
computation okay no
no
infinite precision arithmetic or
anything like that and we're going to
use newton's method but you should
immediately ask how are you going to do
that you've just told me that newton's
method requires exponentially many
iterations the catch was this
the the bad examples where were in the
case when
the extinction probabilities happen to
be all one okay
and it turns out that that is a special
case that we can
deal with separately using some classic
results so um
so
um so it's
for
so being able to decide whether the
extinction probabilities starting from a
given type uh or
maybe another way to say it is um we're
trying to determine whether the least
fixed point of one of these
probabilistic polynomial systems
is
equal to one in some coordinate and this
it turns out you can boil down to
determining whether the spectral radius
of
the moment matrix which is basically the
jacobian evaluated at the all one vector
deciding whether or not that is less
than or equal to one
it it helps basically allows you to
decide whether these
things are one or not and you can do
that in polynomial time you can decide
for non-negative matrix
n by n matrix to decide whether its
spectral radius is less than or equal to
one is easily in polynomial time and in
fact subsequent to us showing that it's
in polynomial time these guys have
pointed out that it's in fact in
strongly polynomial time so you can boil
it down to solving a system of linear
equations okay
and deciding whether a coordinate is
zero is actually very easier it's easily
np time
so okay so what do we do what's our
algorithm find and remove all of the
variables where in the corresponding
coordinates the least fixed point is
zero or one
plug those zeros and ones into the
equation getting a remnant equation all
right
on that resulting system of equations
just run newton's method starting from
zero
okay i i'll tell you later about how to
deal with rounding
issues
uh theorem the theorem says that given a
probabilistic polynomial system with at
least fixed points strictly between zero
and one if we apply newton starting at
the zero vector then all we need are
four times the encoding size of the
system plus j iterations of newton's
method to get j bits of precision okay
and um
now what do we do about round off error
it turns out that
the newton's method is converging
monotonically and if you carefully in a
careful way round down
to a multiple of
a sufficiently
large number of bits but only
polynomially many bits then
if you do that then basically with just
a couple of extra iterations you can get
the same thing okay
so so
basically what this then shows is that
we obtain a p time algorithm in the
standard turing model of computation for
approximating these least fixed points
okay
um let me give you some idea of the the
the proof and i think the the ideas will
be familiar to
to many of you but it will highlight
what's going on so for a probabilistic
polynomial system when the least fixed
point is strictly between
zero and one
this matrix the the
the jacobian
of p prime evaluated at q star is a
non-negative square matrix and we can
show that
if these conditions hold then then its
spectral radius is strictly less than
one
and so that therefore this matrix is
non-singular and in particular newton's
method if you remember is going to be
defined because this thing is
non-singular and since this is
non-singular
obviously we
and since the spectral radius of this is
less than one this equality holds so if
you think about it
a crucial role on the convergence
behavior of newton's so basically we can
show that the number of iterations of
newton's method needed to get within
distance epsilon
is
log of the norm of this matrix plus log
one over epsilon okay
and
now the norm of this inverse matrix is a
as you can appreciate from seeing this
is going to be tied
to the distance between one and the
spectral radius of this matrix right
because the further away you are
from
from spectral radius one the faster
these powers are going to converge to
zero okay
which in turn is going to it turns out
it's going to be closely related to the
distance between the least fixed point
vector and the all one vector
and turns out we can lower bound that we
can in other words we can show
that
when you remove the all one uh vector
when you remove the the one coordinates
not only is it the case that you're not
in the singular case you're sufficiently
far away from the singular case such
that newton's method is going to
converge fast fast
and it's going to basically get you
get you there
in polynomial time even with rounding
now here's another interesting uh
side bit from that remember this pauses
lp problem that i was telling you before
it turns out that
the problem of deciding suppose i want
to decide whether in some particular
coordinates suppose i give you one of
these probabilistic polynomial systems
and i want to decide you know is the
extinction probability starting with
type i
less than or equal to p
this problem is
equivalent polynomial time equivalent to
positive cell p
and the the key reason has to do with
the fact that
basically for these systems we can get
not just quadratic convergence but
quadratic convergence with explicit and
good constants so effectively we can get
a result like this that says with again
somewhat more but still linear
number of iterations of newton's method
you can get uh exponentially many bits
of precision okay
okay
okay now now i want to get to sort of so
far there's been no novel algorithms i'm
just using newton's method as such so
now we're going to talk about
branching markov decision processes
where things will get a little bit more
interesting so now what do we mean by
branching markov decision process it's
just like a branching process except now
we have some types
that you control okay
so i don't know imagine that you're
using these things to model
it's a cancer tumor progression there
are different types of cells and by
injecting some medicine into the
setup you
you put some control over the
reproduction of
yellow cell types okay you you are you
are able to either make them turn blue
but you know go blue or red okay
now you might want to
maximize or minimize the probability of
extinction for example or other
quantities associated with the
stochastic process but now it's a
controlled process
so again
it describes a partially probabilistic
partially controlled
process for generating a random label to
tree okay
so let's write down some equations for
the following what is the maximum
probability of extinction starting with
one red
type
well again for the first three types
again now let x sub r denote the optimal
the maximum probability of
extinction starting with uh one red type
well
here there's no choice
with one sixth probability we're going
to go extinct with one third probability
we're going to generate these guys
from and our goal is still the same to
maximize the probability of extinction
and we have to do it from every one of
those and those are independent things
so
these polynomials
give us
the right equations for these types and
for this last one that's the only new
case is we just have to take the maximum
over
the monomial corresponding to the top
and the monomial for the bottom
notice that the right hand sides max is
a monotone operator the right hand sides
here are all defined a monotone function
the maximum extinction probabilities are
the least fixed point solution of these
systems of equations
okay
again now we can define maximum
probabilistic polynomial systems where
the equations look like this x i is
equal to max of a bunch of probabilistic
polynomials
and we have n equations in n unknowns we
can similarly so so i should have
mentioned we can also do minimum right
so what is the minimum probability of
extinction similar equations except now
we have min instead of max min is also a
monotone operator
the minimum extinction probabilities
define the least fixed point
are are given by the least fixed point
solution
so we've got max pps's and min pps's
these are the bellman optimality
equations defined by
by these things
uh for maximizing and minimizing
extinction probability
uh so
so we'll we'll use max slash min to
refer to these things
again all of the things basically this
is like a carbon copy of what i said
before all of the things i said before
still hold
these define a monotone maps
the least fixed point is
uh you know
it exists it's given to us as the by the
limit of iterating the function starting
from the zero vector
and it's
the least fixed point is what we're
trying to compute
and the question is can we compute these
things
efficiently and p time so before we were
using newton's method but now we don't
have
the functions that we have now have max
and min in them so these are no longer
differentiable they're only
you know sort of piecewise
differentiable if you like so what do we
do how do we apply newton's method to
this
so it turns out we can get
so this
says that there's a polynomial time
algorithm for computing the least fixed
point solution to these bellman
equations
and we do it by a generalization
of newton's method
that uses linear programming in its
iteration but the generalization is very
sort of straightforward to to
describe so let me tell you
everybody
who's looked at newton's method you'll
realize that what is newton's method
doing each iteration of newton's method
basically amounts to
taking your original function
looking at like
the best linear approximation for it the
first order taylor approximation and
solving that
and
using that as your iterator right
now so so this is just what what is this
is what newton's method does so if i it
if i apply newton's method at current
vector y
what i'm doing is
i'm trying to solve
this equation
where
this function is just the
first the linear approximation of the
original function linear approximation
at the point y
okay
now what if i've got max's and mins in
my equations what do i do
so it turns out you can do the following
thing given a max pps
just do the obvious thing so
each coordinate in each coordinate the
function looks like this it's a maximum
of a bunch of probabilistic polynomials
the linearization of this is just the
maximum of the linearization of each of
those pieces okay
okay
so
basically my newton iteration my my
generalized newton iteration is going to
be to compute a fixed point of this
linearization of this function but i
have to be careful which fixed point
greatest or least and i
i can do it it turns out now since i've
got max's in inside my these are now
max linear equations right so i've i've
turned my equations into piecewise
linear
okay and it turns out i can use linear
programming
to solve each of these iterations okay
so
in other words i can turn these
iterations into
uh
optimization problems that effectively
boil down to linear optimization
problems and this constitutes one
iteration of this generalized newton's
method
and now
the the
so what's the algorithm the algorithm is
find and remove all the variables that
are zero or one
now in the case of these branching
markov decision processes it's no longer
about detecting whether a certain matrix
has spectral radius greater than or
equal to one it's about spectral radius
optimization
and it turns out that we can
nevertheless do that using linear
programming so we can detect which
coordinates are one or not
on the resulting system of equations if
we apply generalized newton's method
starting from the zero vector and if we
round down sufficiently after each
iteration then this
computes in you know
can be used to compute
so each iteration is
computed in polynomial time and it gives
us a polynomial time algorithm for
computing in the standard turing model
of computation a polynomial time
algorithm for computing
the least fixed point solution for these
max min probabilistic polynomial systems
so in other words bellman equations for
branching markov decision processes okay
all right so
that's a whole mouthful and so these are
some of the key lemmas that go into the
proof but i can't really describe these
things in any so one can generalize this
to branching simple stochastic games
where you have both max and min
operators and you get corresponding
equations where there's both maxes and
mins
the least fixed point is again the
extinction probability
the optimal values of these games the
actually the values of these stochastic
games and i'm not going to describe that
stuff but let me just
say it like this so we have polynomial
time algorithms for branching mdps and
branching
processes these algorithms also yield
uh np or p in fact pls complexity bounds
for approximating the value of the
corresponding branching stochastic games
so can we use this generalized newton's
method to solve other classes of
plus times max fixed point equations
that's something that i'm interested to
find out where where else can we apply
this kind of thing but what i want to do
now in the last few minutes i know i've
been going rapidly i want to try to
highlight
some open questions that i think are
sort of pivotal open questions at the
core of the complexity issues
surrounding a lot of these problems
having to do with this problem pause
this lp
and and kind of put forward a couple of
uh wacky conjectures or interesting
conjectures associated with those
so remember this pause slp problem
i i just give you a straight line
program with plus times and minus input
just one and you're just supposed to
decide is this straight line program
going to output a positive value or not
we can't just do it do the naive thing
and compute the values because they're
gonna because
we don't have infinite precision
arithmetic okay
so can we get any better upper bounds
than the upper bounds given by alan der
ettel by by peter bergser and
milterson and kilgard
kelgard peterson
so
they give this counting hierarchy upper
bound which is
really we would like to do a lot better
than that
and so here is a
um very basic approach and a
corresponding
conjecture saying that it's done it's
not going to work so my first conjecture
says that a naive approach
shouldn't work but we at the bomb at the
moment we have no idea whether it works
or not
so if you give me a plus times max
circuit
right that's evaluating some integer
right and you want to know whether this
is evaluating a positive integer
well you can just guess a monotone plus
time circuit so in other words just
guess a circuit
that
has input 1 and plus and times gate so
obviously it's going to output something
that's
positive or
you know if you want you could have also
input zero so you you allow yourself to
output zero as well okay
and then that's a witness of positivity
and then all you have to do is certify
that if you subtract the first circuit
from the second circuit the output is
going to be zero right
and that we can do checking whether the
output is zero we can do in co-rp
because in fact it's
equivalent polynomial time equivalent to
polynomial identity testing which many
of you will have heard of this is this
was shown in the same paper by alan
deretal that these problems are actually
palomino time equivalent but in fact the
fact that this problem can be done in
co-rp goes back to shanharga in the
60s or
early 70s or something like that okay
so now
okay
many people here will already know this
notation but so for for an integer a let
tau of a denote the size of the smallest
plus times minus circuit expressing a
and let tau plus of a denote the size of
the smallest monotone plus time circuit
expressing a
okay
so here's a conjecture
there exists
so the conjecture is basically saying
you're not going to be able to pull this
off with just monotone circuits so
there should exist a family of positive
integers
where
the
the n
such integer a n requires encoding size
basically n in other words that that's
the the size of the smallest circuit
you know that it has
but such that for some fixed c
uh
you know we're gonna get basically we're
gonna get exponential
lower bounds for monotone encodings of
those integers we don't know this
for polynomials there's an old result by
valiant
so valiant proved that there is an
exponential lower bound for monotone
polynomials being expressed by so
there's an exponential gap between
monotone polynomials being
expressed by non-monotone circuits
versus
monotone polynomials being expressed by
monotone circuits but the lower bounds
for polynomials don't work
for
integers there's fundamental uh
breakdowns in those arguments okay
and the current state of the art for
this is really abysmal and i don't even
want to tell you what it is because it's
almost you know basically
it's not an exaggeration to say we know
almost nothing about this question
okay
okay
so but what i want to then
say ask is now here is a
maybe more bold or a crazy
uh
thing
so you can do a better approach
let me call a circuit quasi monotone if
it consists of some squared sub-circuit
so maybe a picture will do here
so
what do i mean by quasi-monotone circuit
so monotone circuit is just a circuit
with just plus
and times gates okay and non-negative
inputs or positive inputs here i allow
you to have sub-circuits
that are arbitrary plus times and
minus everything circuits but the catch
is at the end you have to take that last
gate and square it
okay
and that's your input to here okay
so
it's sort of obvious that this
generalizes both uh
it generalizes both monotone circuits
and sums of squares right and we already
know from lagrange's theorem that
already a sum of four squares is enough
to give you any integer but the question
is how big do those
things have to be
there's results in number theory that
tell us that for asymptotically as a
number n goes to infinity the number of
different representations of that number
just as a sum of four squares is theta n
and as the number of different squares
increases that number also goes up but
never mind the the those facts we they
don't have much of a bearing of on this
question at least you know
they don't
but okay so let me
give the the question so
given uh uh
so another approach to certifying
positivity
of an arithmetic uh
circuit would be to guess a pair of
quasi-monotone circuits c prime and c
double prime as witnesses of positivity
for the original circuit and to verify
this equality and i'll re-express that
down here so
so this very optimistic conjecture which
once it can call a very effective
positive styling dots for integers as
kind of uh maybe as a way of giving you
food for thought
says
this works so the hope is that there is
some polynomial such that for any
integer there exists a pair of
quasi-monotone
circuits
whose encoding size is polynomial
in
in the sub in
in n where n is the number of gates
needed to express a in a non-monotone
circuit
and such that a
is
given now i'm i'm conflating notation
here a little bit these are both
circuits and the values that they
evaluate to right
so these c prime sub a and c double
prime sub a are denoting quasi-monotone
circuits they evaluate some value that's
another way of saying this
right
and this equality i can check in co-rp
so basically if this conjecture were
true this would tell me that positive
cell p
not only is it in this complexity class
merlin arthur it would also tell me that
any progress on polynomial identity
testing would give me progress on
placing pause slp in np for example
okay
sorry i'm out of time thanks
questions
do you see the difference between the
max pbs version and the min dps version
or from your from this viewpoint they're
kind of the same well
they are
complexity no they we get we get the
same complex we get but we we're able to
but the proofs are rather different it
turns out
they're not symmetric so the proofs are
require some different machinery inside
uh
to deal with so much version has some
kind of complexity properties
yes that's right so so i mean maybe i so
i
so maybe i can say some things that
might
illuminate that for you so firstly the
thing is
that
the max case one can relate it to a kind
of
uh geometric programming and positive
polynomial form
but even that connection
is doesn't neces by us polynomial time
because the recursive markov chains that
i showed you before i can also encode
those as a geometric programming problem
in polynomial form in effect i get a
result about geometric programming
here's a result about geometric
programming there are geometric programs
in polynomial form
where
they are feasible the feasible set is
guaranteed to be in the unit n cubed
okay
and yet any non-trivial approximation of
simply the optimal value
of the geometric programming problem
is positive lp heart so in other words
so how is that consistent with the
polynomial
it's it it's not polynomial time
solvable unless the feasible region is
full dimensional so methods like the
interior point method and methods like
uh ellipsoid
these these do not have an interior in
general
okay so so basically the the the what i
just told you about geometric
programming i don't know whether word
for word the same thing holds for
semi-definite programming and i think
that's actually
a mildly interesting question so
geometric programming seems to have
a
certain characteristics that make it
even slightly more
uh challenging in a certain respect
than semi-definite but we can talk about
that offline
regarding this last conjecture and as we
know polynomials are easier to
understand than integers now i wonder
what would we get if we um
well is there a similar conjecture for
say real polynomials so you have a real
polynomial non-negative i don't know
that complexity and they want to certify
it i i would it would be easier
so in fact
in fact i don't even know the answer to
the following question so valiant proved
that monotone polynomials
require right now take what i've done
in other words in a sense now you're not
just asking for monotone polynomials but
rational functions of
polynomials of of the right
expressed in the right way
right so in other words these are now
i'm giving you a richer formalism for
expressing monotone polynomials
does there just in the realm of
polynomials is there an exponential
lower bound in other words this would be
a strengthening of valiant result
i i don't know whether that's true
i don't know
so so you know that from from what's it
called arten's theorem we know that you
can write you know but but
so i'm sort of trying to sort of bring
some of that into the con into this
context
i have absolutely no idea you know sort
of
things in valiant theorem as you
yourself know very well this
this lack of cancellation property for
monotone polynomials is crucial and i
don't know how to
you know go beyond
those things so here questions so think
in terms of r why do you need to add the
plus one
well because otherwise i i just want to
be sure i don't divide by zero
and the i can change it
well all i would have to do is in some
other way certify that this guy is not
going to be zero okay and i can do that
by
writing the core p algorithms that
require checking whether that thing is
going to otherwise it looks like a
a rational sum of squares so there's an
argument's theorem but the plus one
changes yeah yeah i agree i agree so so
this is just a clue i i put the plus one
here in order to make sure it's not
going to be dividing by zero
i'll be happy perfectly thank you for
pointing that out i'd be perfectly happy
for anything that certifies
non-negativity of the number a
you know
that is a succinct certificate of
non-negativity of the number a in a
sense what i'm trying to do is simply
cook up as
succinct the mechanism as i can for
certifying non-negativity of a number
right a number that's described by a
non-monotone arithmetic circuit
okay
so
you showed us this conjecture that some
integers are
easily computable by uh general circuits
but heart from monitoring circuits
this previous slide yes all right
do you have a
candidate
so my uh here would be my candidates
okay this
and i'll tell you i in trying to think
about this i've sort of realized that
some intuitions that you might have
about polynomials fail for
for these in for the integer setting but
here would be a candidate
showed his lower bounds for
the perfect matching polynomial for
for planar graphs okay
so he showed that perfect matching
polynomials for planar graphs that can
be obtained by castellan's theorem they
can be obtained by a non-monotone
arithmetic circuit of polynomial size
but he showed that they require
exponential size right
as a monotone circuit now imagine that
you take the variables in
the
in those polynomials
and into the i variable you plug in
an astronomically big number two to the
two to the i
uh
and squared or
to some sufficient power k okay
and by the way this is related to a
trick that was used in the paper by alan
der bergicer and others so you apply you
plug in these astronomical numbers into
those polynomials
right
of course you can you can express these
numbers monotonically easily
right just by repeated squaring
and the the hope the hope the guess the
idea is that those numbers
ought to have the property that you are
not able to express them by monotone
circuits in
polynomial size but you're able to
well you're obviously able to do so by
non-monotone circuits and polynomial
size but i'll tell you uh
i i conjectures that conjectured this
sort of confidently at a workshop in
princeton over a year ago
and i i did i was too naive i i thought
this would be
i thought it would be easy to at least
get super linear lower bounds on these
things and it's
wow it's a real
i don't know
so there's more than a 50 50 chance that
on one of the two conjectures that i'm
giving it's wrong you know so don't
these are just hopes or or something you
know don't
don't take my conjectures as uh
you know
okay any other questions
yes mike that's actually kind of funny
you know i remember
these uh vowel fix points were found by
scarf by the algorithm there's also a
team from princeton
around how koon
yeah and then snail uh to find a global
newton differential equation
right to do the same is your newton's
method the same as smalls global
well it's all newton's method the
question is
under what conditions does it work when
does it work and the the
as far as i understand the the
literature around smail's work and so
forth one has to assume some things
about you know starting at a regular
point and
certain so i don't know whether
the the results there are
kind of this one was a little different
it was the beginning of this whole study
and what they do is take a proof of
browse theory which is
that you can't retract the cell onto its
pull back boundaries boundary values to
define curves
each one of those curves has to tend to
be delivered right
but but it's that's a continuous curve
and so in a sense it's a homotopy method
and the question is whether the
discretization of that might cause any
so i absolutely agree that there's a
continuous i mean you know all of these
the algorithms for converging to
equilibrium amount to some kind of path
following method the issue is whether
the discretizations for it are
um
you know kind of
what if you want to talk about it in
touring model of computation with worst
case complexity and so forth you need to
worry about all of the nitty-gritty
and
that's something i don't know if
somebody had worked out all of those
things for uh for scott for smail's
method but these are all essentially
uh morally speaking very very closely
related uh things
so a class of problems with your
newton's method where it's better than
scars
oh no no but that's a very good point
this is a very special class of
equations so these are monotone
polynomial systems of equations or
monotone min max polynomial systems of
equations where
miraculously magic happens that first
we're able to in polynomial time
eliminate the singular points that cause
nasty problems
and then
after eliminating the singular points it
turns out we're sufficiently far away
from singular so that convergence of
newton becomes globally
fast
right fast and and moreover we can even
do rounding and get the whole thing in
polynomial time so everything is kosher
you know that but but and
you know for more general things
all bets are off and in fact that's why
i was asking this question is like i
would really like to know where else i
can apply this generalized newton's
method
the one where i'm taking the max
polynomial equations and i'm
piecewise linearizing them
and yet it magically works right so
where else does it work
but at the beginning you define this
fixed p class and approximate version
now the upper bound is p space so what
do we know about it uh only p space
so
yeah let me let me try to relate it to
other things that people here might be
familiar with in a certain sense you can
think about this fixed p
as somehow
let me say it like this decision
problems underlying this kind of class
fixed p
sit both in the existential theory of
reals and in the universal theory of
reals okay
we don't know
the decision problems for the
existential theory of reals we don't
know them to be p space hard they're
contained in p space but for all we know
by some magic we may end up being able
to get so so okay here's a even more
wildly optimistic conjecture that
someday in the future we may be able to
put let's say uh existential theory of
reels this is the decision problem for
it we may be able to put it in np with
an oracle for posix lpe don't ask me why
i'm hoping for some if we were able to
do that then and if my other conjectures
hold then
all of those things would collapse
to the polynomial time hierarchy of
course this is a million years away
but i'm just saying that right now we
don't have so existential theory of
reals is
for obvious reasons np hard but it's not
co-npr we don't know that it's co-np
hard and likewise for the universal
theory of reals so fix p is like a total
search problem that's sitting in that
domain and it's both you can because
there's a there always exists a fixed
point you can essentially sort of boil
the underlying problems so in a certain
sense weird collapses would happen we
don't have any pieces
that we don't know
oh certainly not no no we these are not
np hard problems right so yeah so that's
what i was trying to say is that they're
both in the existential and universal
theory of reels roughly speaking and
therefore we don't have np hardness type
results for it so we have time for a
break let's uh thank you sorry